[Applause]
i just got back from the canned film
festival which is arguably the biggest
most influential film festival in the
world hundreds of thousands of people
descend on the french riviera and throw
the glitziest most over-the-top
celebration of cinema
it's truly a place and an experience
like none other i've ever had and as i
emerge out of the fog of espresso jet
lag and amazing movies i want to talk
about what i watched there and my
experience at the festival this video is
sponsored by mubi
my first day at the festival involved
recovering from not getting any sleep on
the plane exploring the area and
watching the new david cronenberg film
in crimes of the future viggo mortensen
and leah sedough play artists where the
loss of ability to feel pain has caused
humanity to start experimenting with all
kinds of weird and grotesque surgeries
as a form of artistic expression it's a
lot of what you'd expect from cronenberg
i think the most interesting thing is
cronenberg is kind of setting up a world
where there's these characters that feel
like the changes that are happening in
their world are very scary and kind of
strike at the core of what they consider
to be human but meanwhile the entire
environment that they live in seems just
like completely inhuman and grotesque to
like our sensibility so there's an
interesting contrast there i like the
performances especially the one from
viggo mortensen uh and i think the world
building is interesting but ultimately
like i left a little bit underwhelmed
this was a great way to start the
festival but in hindsight since this is
coming out in the u.s this weekend
anyway i might have skipped this one and
watched something else while i was there
part of the fun of being at can is
you're in this curated environment and
so you can just walk into something at
random and it there stands a decent
chance that it might be
incredible so while there was a lot in
the fest that i was excited about coming
from directors that i was already
familiar with i wanted to make sure i
walked into at least a few things that i
knew nothing about and i spent my second
day at the festival doing entirely just
that the first thing i went to was a
greek comedy called dodo in this movie
there's a rich family and their staff
and friends and they're kind of
preparing for a wedding
and
having a weird like existential crisis
at the same time
and they find a dodo uh one of the
extinct birds on their property and it's
a weird ensemble comedy the tone is very
strange i think the presence of the dodo
bird is an interesting conceit because
it kind of plants this question in your
mind about
you know extinction or things dying out
and you're kind of wondering the whole
time who or what does the dodo represent
within the dynamic of this family but
the comedy was pretty much lost on me
and i don't think i was alone there were
not a lot of laughs in the screening i
was in i'm a big fan of a lot of the
greek cinema that i've seen but
unfortunately this one for me was just
kind of a miss next up i walked into a
film called pacifiction and i'm sure
this might be an interesting movie but
it's snail's pace kind of exploration of
neo capitalist ennui in the pacific was
really no match for my breakfast and
lunch skipping self at that point so
after an hour of just like confusion
with still another hour and 45 minutes
to go i decided to bounce and look for
some food i would have stuck it out and
i might try to rewatch this later when
it's available
but i would definitely was not the first
person to walk out of this screening so
i don't think it was really landing with
a decent amount of the audience after
stabilizing my blood sugar i walked into
butterfly vision and i had a bit more
success with this one this is a
ukrainian film about a prisoner of war
who is released back to her home and
just kind of the process she's going
through of grappling with the trauma of
her experience and reintegrating kind of
back into civilian society
this is a really heavy film dealing with
a lot of like intense issues that are
very topical and relevant right now to
things that are going on in ukraine i
think the most interesting thing about
this movie was the way they're using
kind of digital
uh artifacts and different forms of
video footage in a very kind of
expressionistic way and i think the lead
performance was very compelling there
was some of the cultural stuff that was
just a bit like over my head some of the
nuance i
am not familiar enough with what's going
on in that region to i think pick up on
all of the nuance of this film i don't
expect this one to make big waves in the
us this year but this was definitely an
impressive debut feature and i'll be
keeping an eye out for more from this
director in the future the last thing of
my second day was close by lucas dawn i
got to go to the gala screening of this
which meant black tie formal wear
walking up the red carpet the filmmakers
being present that was a pretty cool
experience the grand theater lumiere
where they show these premieres is
absolutely massive they pack it full of
people who are really excited to watch
these movies close is a an incredibly
gentle
heartfelt but like brutal gut-wrenching
film it kind of lures you in with this
nice
vibe and then just
hits you over the head with this like
intensity the performances from the two
boys in this film are absolutely
incredible this was one of my favorite
things i watched at the festival this
was what i expected to win the palm dior
it ended up tying for second place
getting the grand prix a24 picked this
up for the us distribution i expect this
to be a big film and probably a favorite
of the year for a decent amount of
people shout out to ethan one of my
viewers who gave me a ticket for this
premiere day three started out with the
new claire denis which is actually the
film that ended up tying with close for
the grand prix this movie is a very
strange joint margaret quali plays this
like drifter journalist who's stuck in
central america and she's just kind of
all over the place like looking for a
way to get back to the us and like her
character the plot of this film is just
like completely manic and erratic and
like all over the place and always going
in weird directions that you're not at
all expecting but it has a very specific
like vibe that i think is interesting
and the way claire denis uses like
setting and location as a backdrop for
the story i think is really interesting
like
her films are really
i get this feeling often about the place
and the people
in
the place is just kind of like
a way of like attracting our eyes
while she like sets up different issues
in the background which i think is
fascinating this definitely wasn't my
favorite thing at the festival but it
was getting a lot of hate from certain
critics and i don't think it deserved
that hate my main takeaway from this
movie is that margaret quality has
quite a career ahead of her if she keeps
up this kind of caliber of work and i'm
really excited to see how that unfolds
then it was one of my most anticipated
films of the festival the new film from
kelly reichardt showing up i really
loved first cow and so i was excited to
see this and fortunately i got to go to
the premiere which was really cool this
movie is
what i've come to expect from kelly
reichardt which is a very sort of gentle
anti-drama but that has like more depth
to it than maybe what meets the eye at
first glance it's about an artist in the
portland art scene and her
landlord and her family and her
co-workers taking care of a pigeon
doing art and it reminds me a lot of jim
jarmisch's patterson just in that it's
very like
calm and mellow
it's about art it's not a hugely
ambitious film but i think it's filling
its shoes perfectly and like being what
it needs to be i don't expect this to be
like a massive hit but if you're a fan
of kelly reichardt it's worth watching
the performance from michelle williams
is amazing she really kind of disappears
into this role
and i can't wait to just re-watch this
one periodically
day four started with probably the most
hyped film at the festival i've been
hearing about it nonstop since i showed
up and this was triangle of sadness from
ruben austland it's a satirical
comedy
like a farce about wealthy society class
social roles it's incredibly irreverent
over-the-top ridiculous it's also one of
the funniest things that i've watched in
a long time there's a set piece in the
middle of this film that is just
bonkers insane one of the craziest
things like i've seen in a comedy film
ever i think white lotus packed into
like a more extreme two and a half hour
film where woody harrelson plays a
marxist
ship captain
i can't wait to see
what people think of this film once it's
out in the u.s and i can't wait to watch
it again i think it's auslan's most
accessible film and maybe his best to
date last thing i got to see was another
very anticipated movie the new park
chanwook decision to leave my friend
julian who was with me at the festival
saw this the first day and was blown
away by it so i was very excited to see
it and this is an amazing film like park
chanwook's direction what he's doing
with composition and editing in this is
really incredible there's like
places he's putting the camera in this
that i've never seen
anywhere else before
i had a little bit of a hard time like
keeping up with the pace of it and all
the details because i was just so
exhausted at this point so i can't wait
to like
re-watch it look at it a few times
really kind of try to break down and
understand what's going on in this film
because it's a really well-oiled machine
i think this one's going to be a big hit
and mubi picked it up
for release so hopefully it'll be out
soon on mubi that's what i got to see
there was definitely a lot that i was
still interested in that i didn't get a
chance to see that i'll be looking
forward to catching up on once it's out
but i'm happy with what i got to see and
i think triangles of sadness decision to
leave and close will probably rank
pretty high on my favorite films of this
year and aside from getting to watch
some cool movies just being in this kind
of environment was pretty cool
it's kind of insane to experience
watching these kinds of movies with
people who are arguably maybe even more
excited about them than me when what i'm
used to in the us is like going to these
movies on opening night
in the midst of like a semi-empty
theater so just being in that
environment that's like celebrating film
in such an intense and crazy way it was
definitely a nice like counterpoint to
this feeling that kind of cinema is this
dying art form it's hard to feel that
way when you're in an environment that
is this excited about it but can is also
a place of like weird contradiction
you're surrounded by five-star hotels
expensive restaurants people in like
expensive tuxedos and dresses walking up
a red carpet and across the bay there's
like luxury yachts and meanwhile like
the movies you're watching are generally
very like humanitarian in focus
anti-colonialist the movie that won the
palm dior this year is just kind of like
a send-up of the entire like elitist
culture that kind of surrounds can the
city and the festival so i found being
in that kind of environment like almost
a very conflicted one i want to read
something that actor vincent linden who
was the president of the jury this year
at cannes said in his opening speech
although when we are crushed under the
weight of current affairs and i find
myself discouraged i do sometimes wonder
if we are not currently dancing on the
titanic and as i was sitting in like
really nice theaters along the french
riviera like watching incredible movies
in this like lavish environment and
hearing about horrific events that were
happening back in the us or like
watching movies about the conflict in
ukraine that was happening like not that
far from where i was sitting i
definitely felt that tension and those
words were kind of like present
in my mind the entire time and i
definitely felt this hopefulness that
like film can be this really meaningful
medium that can inspire change or like
have an impact on the world but then
there's also this tension that maybe in
part it's just another thing that's
distracting from the ship taking on
water in terms of which of those things
it is i don't think i know the answer
but
i think i share lyndon's hopefulness
that film can aspire to something more
and can achieve some kind of
authenticity that if we're going to make
films we might as well aspire to those
heights
he also said in his speech the time of
artists and responsible filmmakers has
come to bear us up and nourish our
imaginations to help us repeat to
ourselves at every opportunity in honor
of all those who are suffering and
fighting in this world be alive and be
aware of it festivals i can in a sense i
think are important and that they give
film something to aspire towards in
terms of artistry in terms of like
meaning that's beyond just you know box
office numbers commercialism for better
or for worse ken is a place where they
treat movies as like a legitimate form
of artistic expression that can really
say something and have an impact on the
world having a place that celeb tries to
celebrate
film in a more meaningful way hopefully
serves as a way to inspire the form to
be the best that it can be one of the
cool things about going to a festival as
i mentioned before is the curation of it
it's fun to just walk into stuff and
hope that you're gonna see something
really amazing and know that like
somebody chose that film or group of
people chose that film for a specific
reason to be a part of the festival you
can get that same kind of experience
with mubi my sponsor for this video mubi
is a hand curated online streaming
cinema they have a whole section called
the can takeover every year while can is
happening with films from past cannes
festivals that you can watch right now
as a part of the can takeover you can
watch austlin's last
film the square that also won the palm
dior in preparation for seeing triangle
of sadness this year that's available
right now on mubi in the us and they
bought some films from this year's can
most notably decision to leave the new
park chan wuk that will be coming up on
mubi eventually i don't know when yet
but mubi is a great way to explore films
in this kind of way get the sort of
festival experience without having to
get accredited for a festival and fly
all the way to france so i definitely
recommend you check movie out today you
can get an extended 30-day free trial
when you go to mubi.com thomasflight
click the link in the description or on
the screen that's
mubi.com
thomasflight
[Music]
[Music]
you